on a des difficultés d'approvisionnement
ou des coûts de matières des coûts
d'énergie qui sont tellement élevé que
je suppose que certains producteurs
préfèrent arrêter leurs boutiques de que
de produire ce cas pas été le cas de
norske skog on a toujours essayé de
privilégier
la production donc la livraison de nos
clients certes avec l'obligation de se
passer
ddd hausse assez conséquente
si on prend notre entreprise et si nous
sommes le dernier producteur français de
papier journal et on envie de dire on
fait des investissements colossaux qui
permettront de pérenniser le cv qui
permettront de continuer à fournir du
journal donc c'est un cercle peut-être
vicieux aujourd'hui mais il faut
absolument que chacun joue le jeu pour
se soutenir les uns les autres sinon
demain dans la plus dure on a dû tout